hey 42 here there are some wild
conspiracy theories out there let's
delve into some of the most recently
concocted theories one of the most
prolific conspiracies of recent times is
the disappearance of Malaysia Airlines
Boeing seven seven five mh370 on the 8th
of March 2014 theories range from alien
abduction - a terrorist hijacking but
one of the most disturbing conspiracies
surrounding the planes disappearance
arose when it was discovered that an
identical plane to Malaysian Airlines
flight mh370 was found in storage at Tel
Aviv's ben-gurion airport in Israel the
twin plane has been in storage at Tel
Aviv Airport since November 2013 the
only difference between the plane and
the one that disappeared over the Indian
Ocean is the serial number so why do
Israel have this identical plane in
storage and what are they planning to do
with it conspiracy theorists believe
Israel are planning a false flag terror
attack on the United States similar to
9/11 where the plane will be filled with
explosives and flown into Manhattan
there are also theories that Iran are
involved in this plumbed attack against
the u.s. conspiracy theorists believe
the real Malaysian Airlines flight was
hijacked and flown to Iran where it was
hidden from public view in preparation
for a terror attack this theory is
backed up by the fact that two Iranian
men boarded the missing mh370 flight
using stolen passports could they have
hijacked the plane well this isn't the
only popular theory others include
involvement from the Illuminati North
Korea and even Edward Snowden it could
be pure coincidence but a reddit user
pointed out that the missing Malaysian
Airlines flight was the four hundred and
fourth boeing 717 built
and we all know where we've seen that
number before another conspiracy of
modern times is that Barack Obama is
trying to bankrupt America conspiracy
theorists believe that Obama is a Muslim
extremist that hates America and wants
to destroy it by any means possible
however it cannot be done by force so
surely the fastest way to see America
fall would be to affect it financially
the u.s. is currently in debt to the
tune of 17 point two trillion dollars
during Obama's presidency campaign he
promised to cut America's deficit by
half but he in fact increased the
nation's deficit by a staggering six
point seven trillion dollars to put that
in perspective during the eight year
term of george w bush's presidency he
increased the deficit by four point nine
trillion this of course has led to
widespread conspiracies suggesting that
Obama secretly has malicious intentions
towards the US if you've had the swine
flu job you may already be a victim of a
rather disturbing theory conspiracy
theorists believe that the swine flu and
bird flu jobs and other vaccines contain
microscopic computer chips invisible to
the naked eye that have been injected
into the population and mass without
them knowing
fevers believe these nano tips will be
used to track and even control the
entire population some believe it has
links to the New World Order and when
the time comes for a mass population
call people who carry the Nano chip will
be able to be terminated at the flick of
a switch fevers back up such theories
with evidence such as these thousands of
plastic coffins being stored in a field
in Georgia which could be used to
dispose of bodies in a mask hole
although others say they are simply
grave liners designed to protect real
coffins from the harsh elements
one of the most outlandish modern
conspiracies surrounds - Lu bings
committee or that exploded over Russia
on the 15th of February 2013 during
mid-morning a flat of light appeared in
the sky over the Russian town causing a
colossal shockwave that shook the
surrounding area
shattered hundreds of windows and
injured 1,100 people the most plausible
explanation is that a meteor entered the
Earth's atmosphere and exploded in the
sky but the creative minds of conspiracy
theorists all over the world came up
with another scenario that the meteor
was actually a manifestation from the
world's most advanced video game the
largest fragment found from the
meteorite could easily fit into a human
hand conspiracy theorists maintain that
such a large object would not have been
so thoroughly vaporized as it seems to
have been the absence of large fragments
supports their theory that an
experimental video game developer
delving into the possibilities of
virtual reality cracked the ultimate
computer code and allowed a video game
experience to manifest itself in reality
could the United States be in cahoots
with North Korea well that's what some
theorists believe the relationship
between the United States and North
Korea is at an all-time low however some
people think it's all just a cover-up
and the two countries are actually close
allies working together there are only
really three pieces of evidence to back
up these claims firstly American
basketball player Dennis Rodman
bizarrely met with Kim jong-un in North
Korea and publicly vowed eternal
friendship with the North Korean leader
the second piece of evidence is simply
that North Korea would have a prophetic
chance if it were to launch a war
against the most
logically advanced military in all of
history so becoming enemies with them
doesn't seem like a very wise idea and
finally in 2012 the United States Center
240,000 ton shipments of food to North
Korea despite relationships between the
two countries already being dire which
begs the question why would they do this
if they're not allies thanks for the
view subscribe for more thoughty2